en directo a Vamos hasta Nueva York
donde se encuentra nuestra enviada
especial y además nuestra cronista de
medio ambiente María Clara calle porque
allí se lleva a cabo la conferencia del
agua de la ONU es la primera vez en casi
medio siglo que se celebra un evento de
este tipo justo cuando aumentan los
llamados a proteger este Preciado
líquido en medio de los impactos
generados por la crisis climática María
clara muy buenas noches cuéntenos Cuáles
son las propuestas que ha habido hasta
ahora en la conferencia de la ONU sobre
el agua
la propuesta más sonada es que se cree
un enviado especial de la ONU para el
agua que es una idea que está liderando
desde el año pasado Alemania por ejemplo
la ministra de medio ambiente alemana
Estefi lem que considera que esta figura
ayudaría a tratar todos los temas del
agua de manera transversal dentro de
Naciones Unidas Y hasta ahora 150 países
han respaldado la idea sin embargo
todavía no es una realidad la segunda
propuesta más escuchada es que más
países se adhieran al convenio del agua
de la ONU que es la que obliga
legalmente a los países miembros a que
pacten acuerdos para proteger las aguas
que cruzan fronteras y a que no tengan
conflictos entre sí El problema es que
esto inicialmente aplicaba Solo para
Europa y desde 2006 se abrió para el
resto de los países de la ONU desde
Entonces únicamente diez naciones han
firmado este convenio el último día en
hacerlo fue este miércoles Nigeria y
otro compromiso tiene que ver con dinero
Estados Unidos prome nueve mil millones
de dólares para priorizar la resiliencia
en temas de agua y saneamiento pero más
allá del dinero la mayoría de los países
se han concentrado en hablar de lo que
han hecho y no de lo que van a hacer lo
cual no va con el llamado de la ONU en
poner el pie en el acelerador para Clara
se ha hablado de que el primer gran
conflicto internacional por el agua
podría darse entre Etiopía y Egipto por
la gran Represa del renacimiento se
discutió este tema en la conferencia de
la ONU
no se discutió sin embargo Egipto sí
puso sobre la mesa el tema de la gran
Presa del renacimiento y dice que traerá
consecuencias catastróficas para su país
y es que este proyecto que Etiopía
comenzó a construir desde 2011 está para
hacer una hidroeléctrica en el Nilo azul
que provee el 85% del caudal de todo el
Nilo por eso el ministro de recursos
hídricos y riego de Egipto hani sueling
dice que esto traerá estas consecuencias
Pues el 98% de su población depende del
Nilo y asegura que Etiopía estaba
haciendo este proyecto sin Consultar con
sus vecinos por eso El Cairo está
haciendo un llamado a tener un acuerdo
transfronterizo al respecto ni Sudán ni
Etiopía han hablado al respecto sin
embargo previamente de Etiopía ha
criticado que Egipto tenga 55 mil
millones de metros cúbicos anuales del
caudal del Nilo que tiene un total de 80
mil millones pero el hecho de que no
esté en la agenda de la ONU ya dice
bastante